chers collègues cette semaine fait
chauffer
s'essouffler le chaud et le froid
l'espoir est des interrogations voir de
la colère l'espoir ce sont les textes
que nous avons voté cette semaine et qui
devrait mettre l'Union européenne sur la
voie de la neutralité climatique c'est
toute la force du projet européen
d'arriver ensemble à construire cette
réponse aux défis climatiques l'espoir
se sont aussi les solutions à notre
portée comme le rappelle le rapport et
qui souligne en particulier l'importance
de la régénération des écosystèmes
marins et côtiers qui contribuent
fortement à l'atténuation du changement
climatique mes chers collègues il nous a
fallu quatre ans quatre ans pour
construire ce cadre alors que les
scientifiques alertes il n'y a pas un
degré une année à perdre chaque demi
degré cette dizaine de degrés compte
certains endroits à l'atténuation et
l'adaptation ne sont pas ne seront pas
suffisants il va falloir même être
résiliente alors je pose la question
dans nos à toutes nos institutions dans
nos débats et notamment dans la campagne
pour les européennes qui s'annoncent
quelle place allons-nous laisser au
climat qui s'emballe quelle place à nous
laisser aux forêts et à l'océan qui
brûlent quelle place allons-nous le
faire à l'action hier j'étais avec l'un
des vices présidents du GIEC et je lui
ai posé la question quel message
faudrait-il passer en une minute il n'a
pas hésité il m'a dit pensons à laisser
une planète habitable à nos enfants